if I uh blindfolded you and dropped you
off in one of the regions would you
quickly recognize the region like by the
food by the music by the accents by so
on yeah the answer to your lovely
question which I think I hope it would
have happened to me is that yes you
would see different cultures yes yeah
but different food most important
different accents yeah or different
languages since they have dialects this
baluch is a different language
altogether
but
or so for that matter Kurdish which is
closer to Persian because they are
Indo-European languages
but Turkish azeri Turkish which is
probably closer to the Turkish of techie
Republic of Turkey or to the Republic of
Azerbaijan in the North
they're the same basically
actually if you would have looked as a
fascinating picture if you have looked
at the let's say even 19th century early
20th century linguistic map of Iran
would have been amazed
in the number of dialects in the number
of languages that has survived and this
is an ancient country it's an ancient
land
and it's a lot of mountains all around
it or big deserts so there's a sense of
isolation so you would say here and
there you see a different community that
speaks differently all ancient
traditions and languages yeah and
because of the great number of invasions
that Iran witnessed over
more than two and a half millennia
of course there are all kinds of
cultures were introduced into Iran
they're all ethnicities were introduced
to Iran mostly coming from the north
east of Iran from
from the uh lowlands of Central Asia and
Beyond and and continued into Iran
proper so but now what has happened
that's what my point that divided to
make uh is the century of modernity or
modernization
has produced
a national culture of great great
strength in a sense I would say I should
ended my book
um the the book on Iran Iran mother in
history uh basically saying that despite
everything else that has created so much
trouble for today's Iraq there is a
sense of a cultural
uh identity that is very strong
and I think
I can say uh with with some confidence
that despite this
despite this regional identities that
are still there and they're great and
they should be celebrated
uh this today if you go to uh to
Kurdistan or if you go to
sistan they all can speak Persian they
all have an education in person so they
all basically are becoming part of
whether they like it whether they like
the regime in power or not they have a
sense of belonging to a culture and an
identity with the center and of course
the idea of a center versus periphery in
Iran is very old it goes back to ancient
times because even the name of the
country was the guarded domains of Iran
this is the this is the official name
namely that it was recognized that this
is not just one uh entity but it's the
it's a collection of entities like the
United States of America exactly exactly
but the United States of America in a
sense you can say that it was a very
successful well it remains to be seen
how successful to be continued to be to
that that was basically invented created
that you would have this sense of it in
in the case of an old nature which has
been on the map of the world for three
thousand years 2500 years there's this
is not an exaggeration I'm not a
nationalist per se but I mean if you
look Persia on the map of the word in
ancient times is still there as it is
today very few countries in the world
are like that
that they would have that kind of a
continuity over a course of time and
that's not without a reason because
there was this sense of it
uh
Center versus periphery that had found
some is it there's a huge amount of
tension but there is also a sense of
belonging to something and state is very
much at the center of it I mean
that's why the concept of a state
matters for the creation for the shaping
of of this culture what happened is
therefore you can see that today in
answer to your point about traveling
blindfolded
is that
you would be surprised to see how much
uh people share
and in terms of I just give you one
anecdote
in
1968 I believe must have been
I traveled to Azerbaijan I I used to
travel and actually photograph not
blindfolded
mostly well yeah
so I went to a Bazaar in the city of hoi
which is in the
Northwestern Iran on the border with
what is today the Republic of Turkey
and I went to the bazaar and I was
interested in the kind of a leather work
that they produced so I tried to buy
some stuff and they were surprised to
see that how few people knew Persia
so they could not communicate in person
with you either they have to ask
somebody from some other store to come
and translate for you
this is 1968 96 so even though it's the
official language was special of the
country that's still yeah so what are
they teach in school so it doesn't
matter it was special but this guy just
doesn't go to school he hasn't been to
the school or he was not fully exposed
to it and of course usually are very
conservative places so it's stuck in my
mind now in recently in 2004 I was
traveling to the same area not to the
same city but to the same area
and I was amazed to see how the youth
as soon as they would know that you're
coming from somewhere else
opening conversation with you talking
about the latest movies that was
produced in the west and it's not only
Hollywood of course there's a huge
amount of fascination with Hollywood and
Western cinema cinema is a major thing
filmmaking is a major thing yeah so
these kids in the city of Ahad were
asking me we're having lunch they're
asking me okay then what do you think
about this producer not producer this
director or that actor American American
European as well but mostly America
were they speak in Persian there's a
complete version that I would converse
with them do they speak English too
interesting Yes actually you would be
surprised to see what percentage of the
Iranian youth at least in big cities are
fascinated with learning language and
for a reason because they think that's
the way to get access either on social
media or eventually leave it on yeah
unfortunately and and because they don't
see a future for themselves in the
country either you have to be part of
this part of this regime
or if you hate them and you don't like
the way of their life you look up
outside you know I was having drivers to
drive me around the country in the
cities around Iran and the guy was a
young extremely well educated
well-dressed and we would have looked at
him we could have found him in any
Street in any country in the western
world and his major concern knowing that
I'm from outside major cases tell me
which would be a better place for me to
go so what's wrong with the place that
you're in right now you are in your own
country you speak your own like no oh
this is no good
I have to have a better future this is
no future for me